[Music]  we needed a miracle and then we got one  this beautiful and special little  creature will be a revolution in the  livestock industry our super pigs will  not only be big and beautiful  they will also leave a minimal footprint  on the environment consume less feed and  produce less excretions and most  importantly they need to taste [ __ ]  good  [Music]  you  [Music]  hey Joe we are animal lovers our plan is  to expose Miranda rescued folk Joe and  bring her back to you he 10 years in  planning on the custom of the products  that will feed millions and what happens  that farmer girl he's gonna destroy us  you should know the situation is not  good  he's not before you go  [Music]  such a shame you have to tell all those  little white lies  ladies and gentlemen  together  [Music]  [Music]  you